il ya frédéric beigbeder écrivain
frédéric qui est un pote de longue date
aussi voilà qu'on apprécie beaucoup
après comme si comme la pression n'est
pas le débat que moi il ya des trucs sur
lesquels je suis pas d'accord avec
ranieri ya des trucs avec les sur
lesquels il n'est pas d'accord avec moi
non mais ça reste quand même quelqu'un
que j'apprécie et frédéric vous vous
avez décidé de quitter paris c'est pour
ça que nous sommes avec vous au
téléphone d'ailleurs nicolas bedos
vous en avez ras le bol c'est ça oui non
mais je veux dire d'abord je soutiens à
1000% nicolas je suis très très comment
dire heureux qui prennent le relais
puisque moi j'ai dit ça en mai dernier
et vous met tous tombés dessus à
l'époque donc je suis content maintenant
ça va être son tour mais il n'est pas le
premier vous savez le premier à avoir
dit ça c'est molière
donc faisons un débat pour ou contre
molière peut-être mais il a dit dans le
malade imaginaire
presque tous les hommes meurent de leurs
remèdes et non de leur maladie l'idée là
de l'état est très paternaliste de
vouloir absolument nous protéger mais en
réalité ça va être des millions de
chômeurs en plus et vous pensez que ça
fera pas de victime mais juste avec a
aussi beaucoup de morts un juste très
directs sur sur la sur la sur le fond il
y en a beaucoup qui sont d'accord avec
nicolas session joue surtout sur la
forme
quand il parle de flicaillons de
rebellions ces sacs ont conquis
reprocher plus mais voilà que le fait
voilà qui disent aux gens c'est vrai
qu'on identifie qu'on a des difficultés
économiques incroyable voilà ça on est
tous d'accord avec lui et sur les
mesures qui ont été prises voilà tout le
monde se dit on sait pas trop si c'est
bien aussi c'est pas bien mais si sûr
surtout le ans mais il est la forme la
rue je comprends mais nicolas bedos
il est il il a écrit un texte
pamphlétaire
donc c'est normal c'est un style il
acquit excessif mais on est dans une
situation où il faut un peu s'énerver
parce qu'il n'y a pas grand monde dans
le camp de la liberté à on est on est
quasiment dans une guerre civile entre
d'un côté la santé et de l'autre la
liberté et il ya peu de voix qui
s'élèvent dans le camp de la liberté
tout le monde a l'air d'accord pour dire
qu'il faut absolument tout interdire
pour sauver des vies alors d'accord mais
pensons aussi à tout ce qu'on est en
train de détruire la culture ça va c'est
vrai ça c'est vraiment les discothèques
oui bien sûr mais je n'y pense oui le
plaisir de se retrouver le plaisir
d'être un être humain social et tout ça
qu'on est en train de détruire non je
disais ça et la dernière fois vous avez
dit pardon jeu j'en profite
bah c'est pas si c'est à dire et quand
contraire que je disais ça parce que je
voulais boire des mojitos avec mes potes
c'est frais c'est bon je vois des
caïpirinhas il frédéric il ya plein de
trucs sur lesquels on peut ne pas être
d'accord c'est que t'as pas été d'accord
avec moi sur plaindre gossip mais ça
n'empêche pas tus et apprécie énormément
et au contraire je suis vraiment pour
voilà qu'on discute ensemble et que tu
vois quand tu aimes exposants que l'on
puisse parler quand tu m'expose ton sur
la latte sur ce que tu as dit il ya
plein de choses sur lesquelles je suis
d'accord avec toi je te dis franchement
si tu as un message à envoyer paître au
gouvernement tu leur dirais quoi agirait
à attention la réalité c'est que vous
n'avez pas fait votre boulot il n'y a
pas assez d'argent pour les hôpitaux
donc il n'y a pas assez de lits de
réanimation et c'est à cause de ça
aujourd'hui on doit tout arrêter toute
notre vie notre art de vivre
on doit l'arrêter parce qu'il n'y a pas
eu assez d'argent d'or dans la dans les
hôpitaux et les milliardaires qui ont
donné de l'argent pour reconstruire
notre dame
il pourrait peut-être aussi donné des
milliards pour les hôpitaux pour qu'ils
aient enfin d'élus et qu'on puisse vivre
il ya beaucoup de gens il ya beaucoup de
gens qui quittent qui disent la même
chose que toi là dessus frédéric en tout
cas merci d'avoir acte avec mme
frédérique
j'espère que tu leur as nous voir un
jour sur le plateau toujours très
intéressant écouter lire et que ce soit
d'accord avec lui merci frédéric
beigbeder